you don't have to be a supermassive
marvel nerd to understand this video not
like me
so i saw the new avengers movie at the
weekend infinity war loved it obviously
because i'm doing this video on it now
for those of you who haven't seen it
there are some mild spoilers ahead in
case you want to wait so did you know
that 60 symbols is actually in the
marvel comic book universe so there's
this one pain of an x-men comic back
from like 2015
where they have like an ipad on the
table and it's clearly on youtube and
down the side
is like number file and 60 symbols
and i'm just like this video is about
the marvel universe and the idea that
someone in the marvel universe could be
watching my video about the marvel
universe like it's so meta so in the
movie there is a scene where some of the
characters travel to a neutron star and
this neutron star is being used as a
weapons forge i was really intrigued by
this idea of whether you could use the
energy from a neutron star to melt metal
i.e melt it down and turn it into a
weapon so in the scene the characters
sort of start up this neutron star they
have to reawaken it apparently okay so
that aside
um
and what they have to do is once they've
reawakened it they have to sort of like
get the energy from the neutron star
onto this bit of metal that they are
trying to melt and some mechanism breaks
down and some grate that needs to be
opened is shut and so one of the
characters thor says okay i'll hold it
open so he takes the brunt of this
energy from the neutron star but he
holds this gray open long enough so that
the metal can melt and he asks how long
do i have to open the grate for and the
other character uh says i don't know
about a minute and i thought would it
really take a minute to melt metal with
a neutron star so a neutron star is the
core of a collapsed star so a star
that's gone supernova they tend to be
around 10 kilometers across and sort of
between about one and a half and three
times the mass of the sun so we're
talking like the size of a city with
three suns in it can we actually work
out
whether the energy we get off a neutron
star is enough to melt metal
into a new weapon of some form and how
long would it take to do that we're fair
is going to have to know how much energy
the neutron star is giving off this is
very well modeled if you treat the
neutron star as a black body and so we
can use the stefan boltzmann law to do
that so the stefan boltzmann law said
that the power given off by somebody j
star is proportional to the temperature
of that body so the temperature of our
neutron star to the power of four i
figured i had to break out the equations
again because everyone commented on how
nice my handwriting was last time and
that they said it should be made into a
font so i was like
i have to do this again
give the people what they want
okay so basically if this is
proportional then there's some sort of
proportional constant in here as well so
instead we can write this as this power
is equal to the stefan boltzmann
constant which i'm going to represent
with a greek sigma that's not a six it's
a sigma and the temperature then it's
not to the power of four okay so this
power is basically the energy radiated
per area per unit time you'll notice
there's a time in there which is good
because we're trying to work out how
long it's going to take this metal to
melt so we can write this basically as
energy over the area that that energy is
being beamed into and the time that it's
being beamed over we have a time in
there so in time for mel and we have a
temperature of a neutron star great so
we need to know how much energy we need
to give the metal in order to take it
from say room temperature to its melting
point okay so again this has been very
well studied we know a lot about it and
it's all to do with the specific heat
capacity of a material the energy you
can put into a material
e is given by
how much mass of that material you have
the specific heat capacity which we
represent by c and then the change in
temperature so this is delta t so this
is a nice scientific way of saying the
change in something the specific heat
capacity is basically how easy or how
hard it is to heat something up so if
you think about when you're boiling
water on a harbor or stove presumably
the pan that you're eating it in is
metal and then you've got the water in
the middle so the pan on the outside
actually gets very hot very quickly with
the direct heat that's on it but the
water takes much longer to heat up okay
so metal basically has a much lower heat
capacity than something like water which
has a much higher heat capacity so it
basically says you have to put more
energy in to increase the temperature of
something we need to work out how much
energy we need to put in to that metal
in order to melt it and then that's how
much energy we need from the neutron
star and then we can work out
over what time the neutron star would
that it would give that out and
therefore how long it would take the
metal to melt the time that it would
take to melt the metal is the
mass of the metal times by the specific
heat capacity of the metal times by
the temperature that you need to
increase the metals temperature by all
divided by area of metal that you're
heating this boltzmann constant sigma
and the temperature of the neutron star
to the power of four nice simple
equation from some nice simple
thermodynamics and it will help us work
out how long it would actually take for
you to melt some metal in a neutron
starforge now we need to figure out some
properties of the neutron star and some
properties of the metal
that thor is melting in the film
to figure out if we could actually do
this i looked up
what metal
though was why are you laughing at me
i looked up what thor's weapon is made
out of and marvel tells us that it is
made out of a metal called uru and it is
a god-like metal and that is all the
information they give you i was like
marvel why aren't you telling me it's
melting temperature oh it's specific
heat capacity i need to know these
things
we can assume some things okay so the
first thing i'm going to assume is that
it has a really high melting point
because it takes quite a while it takes
about a minute in the film to melt this
thing so i'm going to assume that it has
a really high melting point so i looked
up you know metals what has the highest
melting point turns out is tungsten
tungsten has a melting point around
about 3700 kelvin i also need to know
with my equation how much of the metal
that we're heating so again i turned to
marvel and was like how heavy is thor's
uh weapon so unfortunately they don't
quote a wait for his new weapon the one
that he's forging in the new in the new
film in infinity war but they do quote
his old weapon his hammer they quote it
is
19.19 kilograms which seems like to me
but whatever and i'm gonna assume that
basically they're heating about a meter
squared ish of metal just to make the
numbers nice and simple then we also
need to know the temperature of our
neutron star
so i looked up a couple references that
i could find online and i found one that
basically said that you know typical
neutron star that's not like fresh brand
new formed but sort of pretty early on
in its life it's about 600 000 kelvin so
then we need to plug all our numbers
into our equation so first of all we
need our mass which we know was
19.19 kilograms we needed our specific
heat capacity which was 130
joules per kilogram per kelvin so
that'll cancel out our kilograms here
and then the change in temperature i
mean they're in space so they're
probably not at room temperature but
again i'm going to assume that at room
temperature and i'm going to say you
know we need to go from room temperature
to
um the melting point of tungsten which
we've assumed is the same melting point
as this uru which is about 3
400 kelvin and then it's going to be all
over the area which i said was
about a meter squared that'll probably
be fine and then we're going to times it
by this stefan boltzmann constant which
is
six seven times ten to the minus eight
so it's a really small number and then
this temperature of the neutron star
which we said was six hundred thousand
to the power of four so if we plug all
those numbers in and calculate it would
you like to know how long it would take
to melt the metal with the neutron star
and now no second not exactly a minute
as they say in the film i'm assuming
marvel did this calculation and i'm
assuming they thought that a nanosecond
is too small we'll have to go with a
minute so i thought what about if we
worked backwards from the minute that it
takes in the film to melt the metal we
work backwards to find out what's the
temperature of the neutron star that
they're using on this weapons forge of
nadeva layer
i think that's pronounced right i don't
know
let's now define the properties of this
metal uru and you know if anyone from
marvel is watching i have defined them
to have a melting temperature of about
25 000 kelvin which is kind of the
typical temperature of a lightning bolt
and the specific heat capacity of water
okay
and then if we take our equation that we
had before this time of melts times by
the mass and the capacity and the change
in temperature overall the area and the
step and boltzmann and this temperature
of neutron star we can rearrange this
equation again to give us the
temperature of the neutron star
and so
if you plug in
those properties of urea that we had
before and that the time for melt should
be about 60 seconds
then you get a temperature of the
neutron star of about 8 700 kelvin
so not 600 000 kelvin but in neutron
stars once they're formed they form at
these really high temperatures of like a
million kelvin and then they cool
throughout their lives so if we've taken
a measurement of how hot this neutron
star is at 8700 kelvin
we can therefore work out
how old this neutron star is in terms of
like how long it has been cooling for
to get from 600 000 kelvin to 8700
kelvin the way that it's modeled how the
neutron star cools is as a black body
again and so we're going to use the
exact same equation that we had before
for the time of melting
but instead for the time that it takes
the neutron star to cool but instead
we'll be using the specific heat
capacity of the neutron star
and the change in temperature will be
from 600 000 kelvin to this 8700 that we
had before okay so first of all i had to
try and find a specific heat capacity of
a neutron star which turns out is you
know very woolly amazingly enough it's
very difficult to measure how hard it is
to heat up a neutron star or to cool
down a neutron star
but there are a couple measurements that
i found in the literature so i did find
one in one paper that said
that specific heat capacity was 1 x 10
to the 29
joules per kelvin so if we plug all
those numbers into the equation that we
had before and we assume that our
nutrients this neutron star is about 10
kilometers across then we get a time
that this neutron star has been cooling
for of 46 million years
which is entirely plausible because you
know the universe is about 14 billion
years old so
you know that's nothing in the history
of the universe but it's definitely sort
of lifetime of humans and gods and earth
especially so you know we can poke holes
in the whole scene but this nice little
bit of thermodynamics and school physics
really shows us that you know this could
actually
be possible in a way
to take the energy from a neutron star
at least there would be enough energy
there
how you harness that energy and how
you sort of you know collimate it down
into a beam
to get it to
melt the actual metal itself is another
problem for another day
but the idea is that the energy is there
in the neutron star if you would need it
do the exact opposite and that's what
quantum entanglement is poor will
trapped in this parallel universe if
this entire universe
was quantumly entangled with our
universe then anything that will does in
the parallel universe has to be
reflected in our universe as well the
particles have to do the exact
you